solve the system of equations by
graphing check your solution
algebraically so let's graph each of
these let's start let me find a nice
dark color to graph these let's let me
graph this top equation in blue this
parabola so the first thing to think
about is this going to be an
upward-opening well one how did I know
it's a parabola and that's because it's
a quadratic function we have an x
squared term we have a second-degree
term here and then we have to think
about it's going to be an upward opening
or downward opening parabola and you see
it's a negative coefficient in front of
the x squared so it's going to be a
downward opening parabola and what is
going to be its maximum point let's
think about that for a second so this
whole term right here this whole term
right here is always going to be
negative so it's maximum or it's always
going to be non positive x squared will
be non-negative when you multiply it by
a negative it's going to be non positive
so the highest value that this thing can
take on is when X is going to be equal
to zero
so the vertex of this parabola is when X
is equal to zero and Y is equal to 6 so
X is equal to 0 and Y is 1 2 3 4 5 6 so
that right there is the highest point of
our parabola and then if we want we can
graph a couple of other points just to
see what happens so let's see what
happens when when let's say X is equal
to so let me just draw a little table
here so when X is equal to 2 what is y
so negative x squared plus 6 so when X
is 2 what is y you have 2 squared which
is 4 but you have negative 2 squared so
it's negative 4 plus 6 it is equal to 2
and the same thing when X is negative 2
because you put negative 2 there you
square it then you have positive 4 but
you have a negative there so it's
negative 4 plus 6 is 2 so you have both
of those points there so 2 comma 2 so 2
comma 2 and then you have negative 2
comma 2 negative 2 comma 2 and then if I
were to graph it I could even do a let's
try it with 3 as well so if we put a 3
there 3 squared is 9 you then it becomes
a negative 9 plus 3 becomes negative 3
and negative 3 will also become an 8
three right negative three squared is
positive nine you have a negative out
front becomes negative nine plus six is
negative three so you have negative
three negative three and then you have
three negative three so those are all
good points and now we can graph our
parabola our parabola will look
something
oh I was doing well until that second
part let's see our parabola will look
something like that let me just do the
second part that second part is hard to
draw something parabola almost let me do
it from here almost it looks something
like that
there well now let me connect this dot
right here and then let me connect this
so it looks something like that that's
what our parabola looks like and
obviously it keeps going down in that
direction so that's that first graph now
let's graph this second one over here y
is equal to negative 2x minus 2 this is
just going to be a line it's a it's a
lot it's a linear equation the highest
degree here is one so our y-intercept is
negative 2 so 0 1 2 our y-intercept is
negative 2 and our slope is negative 2
so if we move one in the X direction
were going to go 2 in the Y direction if
we move 2 in the X direction we're going
to move down 2 down for the Y direction
we're going to move down 4 if we move
back to we're going to move up 2 in the
Y direction and it looks like we found
one of our points of intersection and
let's just draw that line so that line
will look something like it's hard for
my hand to draw on that let me let me
try as best as I can
so it will go something that my hand is
having my tablet this is the hardest
part it will look something like that
right there and so the question is where
do they intersect well one point of
intersection does immediately pop out as
at us they asked us to do it graphically
that point right there which is the
point negative 2 2 which is the point
negative 2 2 seems to pop out of so this
is point negative 2 2 and let's see if
that makes sense
when you have the point negative 2 well
at it when you put X is equal to
negative two here negative 2 times
negative 2 is 4 minus 2 y is equal to 2
when you put negative 2 here Y is also
equal to 2 so that makes sense and then
there's going to be some other point way
out here where they also intersect
there's also going to be some other
point way out here if we keep making
this parabola let's see when Y is equal
to positive 4 then you have negative 16
plus 6 you get negative 10 so positive 1
2 3 4 and then you go down 10 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 that looks like that might be
our other point of intersection so let
me draw let me connect this right there
and then our other point of intersection
looks to be right there if we if we just
follow this red line it looks like we
intersect there and let's verify that it
works out so 4 negative 10 we know that
that's on this blue line let's see if
it's on this other line so negative 2
times 4 minus 2 that is negative 8 minus
2 which is equal to negative 10 so the
point 4 negative 10 is on both of them
when X is equal to 4 y is negative 10
for both equations here so they both
definitely they both definitely work out